[Música]
estudia para un examen trata de hacer
más cosas de las que le permite el
tiempo el estrés es una sensación que
todos tenemos al ser desafiados o
abrumados pero más que solo una emoción
el estrés es una respuesta física que
viaja por todo el cuerpo
a corto plazo el estrés puede ser
ventajoso pero cuando se activa con
mucha frecuencia o por demasiado tiempo
la respuesta primitiva al estrés no sólo
cambia su cerebro sino que también daña
muchos otros órganos y células del
cuerpo
la glándula suprarrenal libera hormonas
del estrés cortisol epinefrina también
conocida como adrenalina y norapinefrina
conforme viajan estas hormonas por el
torrente sanguíneo llegan fácilmente a
los vasos sanguíneos y el corazón la
adrenalina hace que el corazón lata más
rápido eleve la presión arterial y con
el tiempo provoca hipertensión el
cortisol puede hacer que el endotelio el
revestimiento interno de los vasos
sanguíneos no funcione con normalidad
los científicos saben ahora que este es
un paso temprano en el desencadenamiento
del proceso de la aterosclerosis O placa
de colesterol acumulada en las arterias
estos cambios aumentan la posibilidad de
ataque cardíaco o derrames cerebral
cuando el cerebro detecta el estrés
activa el sistema nervioso autónomo
a través de esta red de conexiones
nerviosas su gran cerebro comunica el
estrés a tu entérica o sistema nervioso
intestinal
esta conexión cerebro intestino puede
perturbar las contracciones rítmicas
naturales que mueven los alimentos en la
barriga que llevan al síndrome del
intestino irritable y puede aumentar la
sensibilidad intestinal al ácido y hacer
más probable que sienta acidez estomacal
a través del sistema nervioso intestinal
el estrés puede cambiar la composición y
función de las bacterias intestinales
que pueden afectar a la salud digestiva
y general hablando de la digestión el
estrés crónico afecta la cintura Bueno
sí el cortisol puede incrementar el
apetito se dice que el cuerpo repone las
reservas de energía con alimentos muy
calóricos y carbohidratos y hace que
usted prefiera comida reconfortante
altos niveles de cortisol pueden hacer
que esas calorías adicionales vayan al
vientre profundo
este tipo de grasa No solo hace más
difícil abrochar los pantalones es un
órgano que libera hormonas y químicos
del sistema inmune llamadas citoquinas
que pueden aumentar el riesgo de
desarrollar enfermedades crónicas como
enfermedades cardíacas y resistencia a
la insulina Mientras tanto las hormonas
del estrés afectan las células inmunes
inicialmente ayudan a luchar contra
Invasores y sanar después de una lesión
pero el estrés crónico amortigua la
función de algunas células inmunitarias
lo hace más susceptibles a infecciones y
reduce la velocidad de sanación quiere
vivir una larga vida puede que tenga que
frenar el estrés crónico Esto se debe a
que incluso se ha asociado a telómeros
acortados los extremos de los cromosomas
que miden la edad de una célula los
telómeros recubren a los cromosomas y
permiten que el ADN se copie cada vez
que una célula se divide sin dañar el
código genético y se acortan en cada
división celular si los telómeros se
acortan mucho la célula no puede
dividirse y muere como si todo eso no
fuera suficiente el estrés crónico tiene
aún más maneras de sabotear su salud con
acné pérdida de cabello disfunción
sexual dolores de cabeza tensión
muscular déficit de atención fatiga e
irritabilidad
Qué significa todo esto para usted su
vida siempre estará bajo situaciones de
estrés pero lo que importa a su cerebro
y a todo su cuerpo es la manera de
responder a ese estrés si puede ver esas
situaciones como desafíos que puede
controlar y dominar más que como
amenazas insuperables le irá mejor en el
corto plazo y estará saludable a largo
plazo
si la administración del tiempo es una
de las cosas que le causa estrés tenemos
algunos consejos para usted de parte de
las computadoras descubra en video lo
que las máquinas tienen para decir
[Música]